on commence par du baseball une finale
de première division rageante pour les
coupgardes montinil bretonux il perdent
le titre sur le dernier match après
avoir égalisé à deux victoire partout
sur le terrain de Montpellier il
s'incline finalement dans la dernière
partie sur le score de 8 à 0 c'est la
deuxème finale perdue par les cougards
sur les deux finales disputé en football
enfin une victoire pour le FC Versailles
dans le championnat de National les
Versaillais se sont imposés ce vendredi
sur la pelouse de chaturou sur le score
de 2 à0 à l'occasion de la 6e journée
les buts sont signés Tibo Jacques sur
penalty Chris Kevin
après ce résultat les joueurs de la cité
royale pointent à la 13e place du
championnat prochain match à domicile au
stade jeanoin de Paris contre
Ville-Franche beaujolé toujours en
football ont joué ce weekend le 3è tour
de la Coupe de France plusieurs équipes
zinoises étaient en LCE les principaux
résultats où il s'impose contre Roy mal
maison 3-1 hardardriour s'incline contre
cclou 2-1 chambourser a perdu sur son
terrain 5 à2 contre é Sartrouville gagne
contre Vitri 2-1 et traap s'est
facilement qualifié pour le 4e tour
contre d'ourdan le score 6-1 ce 4e tour
tour est programmé le 1er octobre les
clubs de National 2 feront leur entrée à
cette occasion en rugby fortune diverse
pour les équipes internationales
installées dans les éimine pendant cette
Coupe du monde les Tonga installé à
Croatie sur scène ont perdu face au
favoris irlandais sur le score de 59 à
16 de leur côté le pays de Gal qui a
pour candbase Versailles s'est imposé 28
à 8 contre le Portugal en tennis le
tournoi international de la ville de
Plaisir s'est terminé ce dimanche 17
septembre la finale a tenu toutes ses
promesses au bout du suspense c'est
l'Allemand mats Rosen CRZ qui l'emporte
face au Français Antoine Wang le score
63 67 76 le tournoi international de
plaisir reviendra l'année prochaine pour
une nouvelle édition on termine par du
golf deux cador du circuit ont confirmé
leur participation à l'Open de France
2023 l'Américain Billy orchet le jeune
prodigieux sud-coréen Tom Kim
participeront à la compétition qui se
déroulera du 21 au 24 septembre au Golf
National de 550 an en livlin du côté des
Français livlinois Antoine Rosner sera
de la
partie